oh how are you guys how are you swarthy
and Mediterranean and I have a very sexy
voice don't I very nice
tell em Sam a sexy voice oh I think it's
the sexiest voice I have heard since and
since Howard Cosell close enough I'll
take that very nice that now I want to
get to the truth here I see you are you
cooking yeah no I I watch you guys I
want you guys constantly but I'm gonna
approach this like couples therapy I
want to play one off the other and I
want to get to backstage yeah that's why
I'm out of breath well all that music
you know it kind of we did the light
fantastic back there you were dancing
what kind of dance were you doing well I
called jitterbug you know for my
generation jitterbugging as you go
around like this you know twirl the lady
around of course I'm getting a little
long in the tooth and so I didn't order
that much or else we would have fallen
flat on our you know what
so I so you weren't break dance or
anything back there was something very
what that is you don't know what that is
at all you know what the bunny hop is
yes I do we weren't doing that oh now
what's uh you guys of course worked so
closely with each other do you have yet
pet names for each other well I call her
the coke stirrer which has nothing to do
well I have to say I'm finding out a lot
more than I know if I'm going to do with
what do you call it shooting a line or
whatever that stuff is
cheering Ally hey man hey Sam you are
happy you just stay cool daddy-o I just
think the cokes dry I mean she wrote I
of course since he started calling me
the coke stirs started calling him the
Sam stirrer which rhymes with hamster do
I look like a hamster later ago you sir
out actually max better runs things you
yeah he does he's very assertive very
assertive guy well you know the hamster
sounds like it's like it's some mad
scientist studying the sex life of right
thank you I'm totally confused about the
sex life of when he I'm getting so much
good stuff so fast it's like my head is
reeling they said if we were very good
you know you'd throw the rest of the
carrot top would come back tomorrow or
something no you're gonna stay here in
witness carrot-top the last thing I do
now are there any things that you do
that annoy each other I understand that
that Sam is a peculiar way of eating a
donut that bothers you it doesn't really
bother me I've gotten used to it but
before we go on the air on Sunday
morning Sam I know that this is hard to
believe but Sam sometimes needs energy
this is hard to believe is right
I got a sugar fix
[Laughter]
I will Sam I love the way you say things
I just do just do me one flavor Sam just
say but Captain Kirk that's illogical if
you do that I'll give you my I'll give
you my watch if you say Leonard Nimoy
and I were joined at the hip I do have
the pointed in the eye but Captain Kirk
that's illogical morning and there are
I'm not making this up a dozen chocolate
donuts sitting out there now I never
know exactly how many eats but what he
does is he eats just the chocolate off
the top well it leaves this little
carcass this up so he rotates the
doughnut and he gnaws there's a little
carcass of the doughnut and what does he
do with that throws it away you throw
away the rhein of the doughnut I have no
comment I think it's the most ridiculous
story I've ever heard
you wonder why she calls you a hamster
[Music]
no we do who are you by the way an
audience member um we're gonna just take
a quick commercial break there's so much
more to talk about we haven't even ah so
much good stuff Sam Donaldson and Cokie
Roberts when we come back sticker